hey guys it is the 15th of ox her but
today my name is just and here's the
stuff that's worth knowing about in
gaming the Sosa have released a live
action trailer for fallout 4 and it's
pretty damn cool underscored by the
wanderer by american singer-songwriter d
on the trailer shows of a vault dweller
and puppy pal dogmeat taking a stroll
around the post-apocalyptic wasteland
reportedly Bethesda were working with
filmmaker Guillermo del Toro's
production company mirada studios
although their involvement in this
trailer isn't confirmed fallout 4 will
be out in less than a month on November
10 signups for dooms multiplayer alpha
have gone live and here's the things you
need to know about that the Alpha has
been described as a series of
development driven tests designed to
stress test against dedicated server
infrastructure in a real-world consumer
environment as you can probably guess
the contents of said alpha will be
fairly limited there will be one map
available heat waves and you'll only be
able to try out the 6v6 deathmatch mode
items available include a personal
teleporter and frag grenades and weapons
will include the vortex rifle super
shotgun repeater rocket launcher static
chemin and plasma rifle there will be
one revenant transformation which gives
you rocket launchers and the jet pack
which you can snag by hitting the demon
to bring the first and one power weapon
which shoots through walls and offs
enemies in one shot to be in for a
chance to get into the doom alpha you'll
need to have pre-ordered Wolfenstein the
new order and subsequently already
snagged yourself access to the doom
closed beta no shadow for the alpha or
beta has been announced as yet finally
the legend of zelda twilight princess
might be getting an HD remake Eurogamer
reported that a fan apparently
discovered a shop icon to twilight
princess in the back end of the wii u
eshop an entry for The Legend of Zelda
Twilight Princess HD has also been found
on
nisha servers the game was first
released in 2006 for the gamecube and
wii there's been no official comment
from Nintendo but if this turns out to
be true it won't be the first Zelda game
to get the HD remake treatment on with
you legend of zelda the windwaker was
remade and released in 2013 then we have
done in that comment box if you'd be
keen to play a remake of twilight
princess or not and fly you can enter
gamespot we've got stories on the latest
update for GTA 5 and taylor 5s pre light
that is all the good stuff i have see
you today as always let me know what
mattered to you and check back tomorrow
for our top five stories of the whole
week